[Music]
between hawaii and california in an area
about twice the size of texas is the
great pacific garbage patch
for decades tons of our plastic debris
has accumulated there because of
swirling ocean currents
it looks like a cloudy soup and that's
because the plastic objects are spaced
far apart and they range in size from
large debris to microscopic
there are at least four other garbage
patches like this in the world
and after scientists discovered them
starting in the 90s
they thought that this might be where a
lot of the plastic ended up
out there floating on the surface
but recently scientists brought large
nets to the great pacific garbage patch
and took a closer look at the objects
they pulled out
they found water bottles
and hard hats
and bottle caps and toothbrushes and
toilet seats
and laundry baskets
and using what they found they were able
to calculate how much debris was in all
of the garbage patches
there were about few hundred thousand
tons of plastics at the surface of the
ocean which is a huge number
it is a big number but a few hundred
thousand metric tons of plastic is only
about one percent of the estimated eight
million tons of plastic scientists
believe is emitted into the ocean every
year
so scientists have been left
investigating a mystery
where does the rest of the ocean's
plastic go
[Music]
this is clue number one in the case of
the missing plastic a seafloor sediment
sample
it was taken from the bottom of the
santa barbara basin off the coast of
california
it represents a measure of time from
1870 at its deepest layer of sediment up
until 2009 but this period from 1945 to
2009 is where the study authors were
focused on
it's the era of plastic production
in these layers scientists found plastic
fibers and fragments that were one
millimeter or smaller in size
they found more and more plastic
particles as the years went on doubling
every 15 years that rate is nearly
identical to the rate of global plastic
production
as soon as you see a layer of
microplastic you know you pass the 1950s
and that's the legacy of our generation
this is laurent liberton he works at the
ocean cleanup and led the study of
objects in the great pacific garbage
patch and this will be there forever we
know that
the sea sediment study looked at
microplastics particles smaller than
five millimeters
these either come from synthetic
clothing fibers or they are the result
of larger plastics breaking down
we found these tiny particles floating
throughout the ocean and even in the
guts of the ocean's tiniest creatures
like plankton
but the sediment study shows that some
of our plastic is likely hiding
buried in the sea floor too
but here's another clue
this is a plastic bag captured 2500
meters below the surface of the arctic
deep sea
it's one of over 2100 photographs taken
with this deep sea camera part of the
work that we're doing is to
look at the impact of climate change in
the arctic
we use toad camera surveys to look at
the
impact on large animals like starfish
and snails sponges
and while i was doing these surveys
i saw that more more plastic debris was
on the sea floor
melanie bergman's research shows that
large plastic objects don't just float
on the surface or degrade into
microplastic some of them sink without
breaking down
one study found that about 50 percent of
plastic in landfills is more dense than
seawater which means these objects could
sink on their own but even those other
50 percent may actually travel to the
seafloor with time
debris which is floating on the ocean
surface becomes colonized with barnacles
muscles all sorts of different organisms
and then it becomes heavier and heavier
and at a certain point it then starts to
sink
bergman's research is difficult to
replicate throughout the ocean because
of the challenge of surveying deep sea
environments
but it suggests that some of that
missing plastic might be sitting on the
sea floor intact
[Music]
another clue complicates the mystery
though this plastic crate from taiwan
it's one of the objects excavated during
the harvest in the great pacific garbage
patch and what struck researchers was
its production date
1971.
when they looked at the production dates
of other objects they saw a trend
a lot of it was old trash
this was a new lead
because if the majority of plastic
pollution degraded into microplastic or
fell to the ocean floor
then what you'd see in garbage patches
would be new plastic and that changed
the story because the plastic that is
accumulated at the surface of the ocean
is actually very persistent
the plastic we find in subtropical
oceans may actually be there for decades
if not centuries
it turns out the new plastic is far
closer than the open ocean or the bottom
of the deep sea
[Music]
liberton's research found that plastic
objects and coastlines have more recent
production dates than plastic in the
open ocean
this clue led scientists to think a lot
of debris actually stays close to
shorelines around the world
hidden in plain sight some of that will
end up in the middle of the ocean in
garbage patch but actually a lot of it
stays fairly near shore and hops from
beach to beach to beach eric von sabiel
is an oceanographer and is building an
ocean model that predicts where our
missing plastic ends up
the completed model will be finished in
2022 but in the meantime he and his team
publish initial results to a twitter
feed we
use simulations of the ocean currents
and then we put in virtual plastic we
move that plastic with the ocean flow at
the same time the plastic can fragment
it can degrade organisms start growing
on it that ways down the plastic so that
it slowly starts to sink into the deeper
ocean so in that way we're doing like
this gigantic simulation of all the
ocean of all the plastic moving around
van zabiel thinks that a majority of
plastic pollution is within 100 miles of
shorelines
continually getting washed back up on
beaches down coastlines or up and down
to the sea floor
plastic continuously goes back and forth
between the coastline and offshore
that's a lot of
rubbing and fragmenting and scraping
over the sand this commotion helps
explain the presence of microplastics in
sediments and animal guts too
[Music]
laurent's organization is working on
cleaning up the garbage patches in the
middle of the ocean but that won't do
much for the other 99 of our plastic
the microplastics becoming part of our
food web and geologic record the larger
debris sinking to the bottom of the
ocean and more likely than not the stuff
getting washed up on beaches
[Music]
like this one where i recently visited
where i found a mix of micro and larger
plastics
but knowing where plastics end up can
help us keep this plastic keep from
growing
these photos were taken by volunteers at
an annual international coastal cleanup
event organized by the ocean conservancy
where people volunteer to pick up
plastic on the beaches near them
the most common objects they find are
food wrappers
cigarette butts
plastic bottle caps and plastic cups and
plates
the easiest way to get plastic like this
out of the ocean is to prevent it from
entering in the first place with better
recycling programs or producing and
using less plastic altogether
there are nearly 400 000 miles of
coastline around the world
not all of it accessible for people but
knowing that most of our plastic
pollution hangs out along shorelines
before it becomes microplastics or
floats out to the open sea
means beach cleanups can go a long way
in preventing further damage
so if you see plastic pollution on a
beach all the more reason to pick it up
[Music]
you